[Música]
buenos días gusto estar aquí les quiero
contar qué
cuando me invitaron a venir a la charla
terex volví a sentir lo que algún
momento de mi infancia
sentí la primera vez que hable en
público he pasado varios días pensando
que decir cómo decir el orden de decir
el momento que dijo mi nombre me olvidé
de casi todo no temas me acuerdo en unas
pocas cosas
puede retomar el año que decía que había
estado hablando en la politécnica
nacional del ecuador y contaba que decía
a sus estudiantes de física que cómo
funcionaba el universo ese mismo año en
los eeuu un profesor de derecho
christopher esto cuando la corte suprema
de justicia iba a tomar una decisión
sobre un famoso caso por el cual una
organización ecologista llamada sierra
club demandó a walt disney para que no
hagan un campo de esquí en un lugar
donde había seco días gigantes ese
profesor en el año 72 escribió un ensayo
que sea porque no dar derechos a los
árboles en ese momento la humanidad lo
siente los juristas
y les pareció que la idea de esta manera
absurda
el derecho es una construcción humana el
derecho es producto de la cultura es una
construcción totalmente distinta a la
naturaleza sin embargo
casi 40 años después aquí en el ecuador
la constitución del 2008 declaró que la
naturaleza tenía derechos
la pregunta central es por qué no el que
lo hizo ya está la constitución lo dice
es el único país en el mundo que a nivel
constitucional declara a la naturaleza
como sujeto de derechos la pregunta como
les decía no es que se hizo sino porque
se hizo y aquí vienen las dos o tres
respuestas posibles la primera respuesta
tiene que ver con una cuestión puramente
pragmática
el universo el planeta tierra está
enfrentando la amenaza más relevante que
es su propia sobrevivencia los datos
sobre la extinción de las especies sobre
el calentamiento global aunque hay
muchos escépticos aquí deben haber
parado de beber parado muchas veces de
esos escépticos dicen que no que el ser
humano tiene poco impacto en el
calentamiento global la mayor parte de
los científicos dicen que no que tenemos
un impacto tan relevante que si no
tomamos medidas inmediatas nuestra casa
el lugar donde vivimos va a calentarse
tanto que la forma en que conocemos la
vida va a cambiar
pero esta idea de que el universo está
camino a la destrucción no ha podido ser
enfrentada por el ser humano
de ninguna manera normativa es decir
desde el derecho viendo la naturaleza
como una cosa esas leyes
medioambientales en la idea
inmediatamente inmediata es que decir
que la naturaleza es un sujeto es una
forma de reforzar su protección de
mejorar su protección porque el ser
humano en esa relación cartesiana
sujeto-objeto siempre ha visto que la
naturaleza puede ser usada para su
satisfacción y no tiene ningún control
sobre su propia acción porque cree en un
momento además que los recursos eran
infinitos esa lógica de protección
medioambiental puramente utilitaria se
enfrenta a otra a esta idea de que la
naturaleza es un ser vivo
la idea de que la naturaleza tiene una
dignidad intrínseca que nosotros los
seres humanos sólo somos un pequeño
momento en la evolución que no somos lo
más importante somos uno más de la
naturaleza
suena atractivo se decía que en el
ecuador se juntaron dos ideas la idea de
la pachamama de los pueblos indígenas
con la idea de la gallá de un científico
inglés que se llama james lovelock y que
planteó una y una hipótesis después de
una tesis que dice que la naturaleza es
un ser vivo o que actúa como un ser vivo
que las partes todas las partes están
integradas de tal manera que una
alteración de esa armonía va a modificar
las condiciones de vida en la tierra y
de esas condiciones van a hacer que sea
imposible que haya vida es decir que
esas partes se llama homeostasis esas
partes permitan que el ph que tenemos
nos permite vivir y que haya vida al
inicio 6 lobelle o siempre cuentan esto
él veía es un inglés veía la campiña
inglesa como si va destruyendo le
preocupaba la destrucción de su entorno
y se dio cuenta al menos pensó de que si
la gente seguía viendo la naturaleza
como una cosa como un objeto esta
destrucción no iba a parar
y pensó que la solución era proponerle a
la gente que eleve a la naturaleza como
un ser vivo
inicialmente la hipótesis se convirtió
en una tesis en el 2008 cuando el
ecuador declaró a la naturaleza sujeto
de derechos quienes comentaban sobre
este tema decían que en el mismo espacio
y lugar se habían juntado la idea
primitiva de la pachamama el ser humano
como parte del todo con esta idea
científica de james lovelock como la
tierra como ser vivo la gaya
sin embargo cuando empecé a estudiar
esto y de ahí les cuento porque empecé a
estudiar las razones descubrí que no
había una sola línea en el ecuador
escrita sobre este tema sino hasta más o
menos los años 90 finales de los 90 y
esas líneas lo que decía era un profesor
vladimir serrano que hablaba sobre esta
tesis de un profesor chileno que
declarara la natura de sujeto derechos
de una obligación porque se tenía que
cambiar de una visión antropocéntrica a
uno biocéntrica y que nadie en la
constituyente del 2008 tenía entre sus
planes de clara la naturaleza sujeto
derechos nadie ni siquiera los indígenas
en la idea vino de la mano de una
organización norteamericana que venía
promoviendo el cambio de leyes
ambientales en los eeuu que se acercaron
a hablar con el presidente de la
asamblea en ese momento alberto acosta y
cuando conversaron con él descubrieron
que tenían un aliado porque alberto
acosta les dijo los seres humanos
tratamos a la naturaleza como que fuese
un esclavo
al inicio los movimientos indígenas se
opusieron a esta idea se pusieron por
una razón bien simple si la naturaleza
tiene derechos y las comunidades tienen
derechos territoriales significa que sus
derechos sobre el territorio podría ser
limitado por los derechos de la
naturaleza
pero después cuando se aprobó la
constituyente
han defendido como que esto fuese su
idea está bien en la evolución de las
ideas es así al inicio no se resistía a
aceptar después aceptaron y ahora
consideran que es parte sobre indicación
lo que parece que es una gran novedad
esta idea biocéntrica encierra un
peligro un peligro tremendamente grande
para los derechos de las personas es
verdad
la tierra ha sufrido mucho uno de los
mayores retos de la humanidad es ver
como alimentamos a 6 mil millones de
personas
como el gasto energético que tenemos es
compatible con la supervivencia en la
vida y con la naturaleza tenemos el reto
de evitar que siga existiendo la
desaparición de mil especies de animales
de bosques nativos efectivamente todos
está bien sin embargo quienes defienden
esta tesis biocéntrica nos dicen que
regresemos a pensar en el pasado como
los antiguos pueblos es decir que
creamos como una religión que todas las
conexiones hacen que nosotros seamos
parte de la piedra del otro ser humano
de la montaña y el bosque y que no
podamos explicar por qué sucede esta
vuelta al pasado tiene otro problema que
pasa cuando se enfrenten los derechos de
la naturaleza con los derechos de las
personas quien va a primar les dirán los
derechos de la naturaleza obviamente si
esa es nuestra casa común como que si
nosotros tuviéramos una posición
secundaria la vida
no me malinterpreten no estoy diciendo
que no hay que hacer nada y tampoco me
malinterpreten pensando en que estoy
diciendo que la mirada de los pueblos
indígenas la mirada de los pueblos
ancestrales no es una mirada inteligente
interesante e importante tan valiosa y
tan relevante como la nuestra la vida
occidental lo que estoy diciendo les es
que no podemos sentar las acciones de
protección del medio ambiente sobre unas
creencias son como una religión
porque tal vez el mejor aliado que tiene
la humanidad para enfrentar las
transformaciones y los cambios es la
ciencia tal vez la mejor opción que
tiene la humanidad es entender cómo
funcionan las cosas y a partir de la
razón tomar las medidas nosotros como
seres humanos si somos un pequeño
instante la historia del universo
millones y millones y millones y
millones de años para que nosotros
estemos aquí somos el último segundo de
esa historia universal nos creemos tan
importantes que sentimos que podemos
asignarle a la naturaleza
una característica humana
los derechos son de las personas porque
el derecho sólo sirve para el
comportamiento humano las leyes de la
naturaleza no tienen nada que ver con
las normas jurídicas las normas
jurídicas son invenciones son
construcciones intelectuales
de esta manera nosotros si no entendemos
que esta idea que nos parece tan
novedosa es peligrosa estamos corriendo
hacia cuatro ideas cuatro ideas
principales que tiene el biocentrismo lo
que se llama el ecologismo radical la
primera
los pueblos ancestrales son los que
tienen la fórmula de vida para vivir con
armonía con la naturaleza es una idea
parcialmente falsa efectivamente los
pueblos ancestrales viven en mejor
relación con la naturaleza
bryce suficientes evidencias de que los
seres humanos en el pasado provocaron
extinciones masivas y destrucción de su
entorno si ustedes ven lo que pasó con
la isla de pascua si ustedes se fijan lo
que pasó en centroamérica el ser humano
es el ser humano primitivo provocó una
extinción y una destrucción de su
entorno esta idea de que los pueblos
ancestrales tienen menor impacto
ecológico tiene una base son comunidades
más pequeñas donde la economía de
subsistencia no es tan peligrosa o tan
dañina para el medio ambiente
esto viene la segunda idea cuál sería la
mejor forma de vivir te dice cómo viven
los pueblos ancestrales es decir en
pequeñas comunidades en economías de
subsistencia donde el todo el uno es
parte del todo y por lo tanto la
expresión individual quede eliminada los
derechos de las personas estarían
sometidas a esta expresión del todo la
tercera idea el capitalismo que el
mercado es intrínsecamente mala y que
por lo tanto hay que cambiar de modelo
económico y la cuarta idea que la
tecnología es intrínsecamente
ahora bien la respuesta evidentemente no
viene por el lado de las cosas que han
fallado
que hemos probado como humanidad para
evitar el desastre ecológico en un
tiempo usar el derecho civil tal vez
muchas de las personas que están aquí no
son abogados y abogados y el derecho
civil básicamente es el derecho de las
personas y sus relaciones entre iguales
y el tema de la propiedad la primera
opción de proteger la naturaleza viene
por lo que se llama el derecho de daños
que la gente repare cuando causa un daño
no funcionó la segunda opción es el
mercado poner un impuesto al carbono
poner una carga económica a las
actividades ambientales tampoco ha
funcionado la tercera opción es el
derecho medioambiental que empezó en la
década de los 70s cuando bruce llegó al
ecuador es esta idea de límites poner
límites de la actividad humana pensando
en proteger al ambiente tampoco ha
funcionado la cuarta idea venía del
derecho internacional de los derechos
humanos que es pensar que la naturaleza
es importante el medio ambiente es
importante para que las personas podamos
vivir nuestros derechos
chino medio ambiente adecuado no podemos
sobrevivir si un medio ambiente adecuado
no podemos comer sin un medio ambiente
adecuado no podemos conocer nuestros
derechos y tampoco ha funcionado muy
bien por eso la opción de los derechos
de la naturaleza posiblemente desde la
perspectiva biocéntrica desde esta
perspectiva que nosotros somos de esta
parte del todo y que nos piden que
creamos como una religión puede ser
peligrosa pero tiene otra vía
la vía de creer de construir un relato
un relato que reemplace el relato
anterior el poder de la imagen de la
naturaleza como un sujeto de derechos y
como alguien que tiene derechos tiene un
poder simbólico profundo y potente a
pesar de que en el ecuador se declaró la
naturaleza como sujeto de derechos hay
una paradoja el único límite en el
ecuador de la explotación medioambiental
es el límite humano
te recuerda lo que pasó con yasuní y la
consulta que se hizo para los días
unidos reunieron miles de firmas que el
gobierno anterior las desapareció
mágicamente
hoy y que es hoy día y preguntaban si
podemos explotar el yasuní
porque necesitábamos los recursos y el
único límite imposible de salvar el
único límite insalvable era la presencia
de pueblos no contactados el ministerio
del ambiente lo que hizo es mover la
línea y dijo antes le veían en este
lugar donde en realidad no era esta
línea era acá y autorizaron la
explotación
ahora están en el centro de quito
reclamando porque quien abrir un nuevo
campo petrolero y este viene la última
parte de mi invocación si no hacemos
algo
probablemente vamos a hacer polvo de
estrellas otra vez seguramente el reto
más importante este momento para la
humanidad es sobre su sobrevivencia pero
sobrevivir no pasa por aceptar cualquier
cosa tenemos que aceptar que la razón es
la mejor explicación a lo que nos rodea
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]